Um,
we hired somebody to help us with the
business that was just,
I should have,
you know,
when you say you should listen to your
instincts.
And we were feeling like we were,
I don't want to say overwhelmed,
but we know we needed a consultant for
something and we knew we needed a
consultant but weren't really sure how
to address it.
And somebody had recommended somebody
and we both felt,
you know,
there was something off.
And then it turned out to be very,
very off.
And I'll,
I'll look at it that it was a learning
experience and it could have been a lot
worse.
And you know,
we caught it at the beginning and now
it's almost done.
But it's the newest mistake.
I don't,
and I think he might not hear it is the
worst mistake.
I guess.
Maybe because he was toxic.
I mean,
that was the worst.
It was just someone who lied and cheated
and you know,
and it happens.
I mean,
it's human nature.
Sure.
A lot of mistakes,
but nothing like big or bad.
Yeah.
I mean we,
we usually catch them at a certain,
I mean the good news is when you're
relatively small or yours,
make mistakes,
so relatively small as well.
And when you're big it can be colossal.
And so as a young,
very supple company we can recover from,
but everyone makes mistakes.
I think the real question is do you make
the same mistake twice?
I think it's is important.
I think,
um,
probably should have done,
do more due diligence.
I think it was just,
we were,
the business was moving very,
very fast and frantically,
we know we needed somebody and we were
like,
alright,
let's just do it.
Well,
we've,
we've made,
we've made higher.
We've had hires that have been sort of
got responses which have been great and
others that have not.
And we've had other hires that weren't
necessarily a gut response,
but they were hired nonetheless and
again,
terrific ones where we weren't
necessarily,
you know,
the lesson after two,
three weeks,
what you have.
And we probably should've reacted,
uh,
more quickly than we actually did
for a company of our size.
The thing that I think is most crucial
in terms of what we do is hurting
somebody that culturally is a good fit.
And if they're smart and they fill the
position in a,
in a manner for which they have
experience or we feel is appropriate,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Having the cultural fit and the passion
for the business is probably the biggest
hurdle because we're only 20 people of
which,
you know,
10 of those are working sort of right
out of our office in New York City.
And I think that's the most crucial
aspect of,
of where we are for this size today.